ABBY CAREY: Hey, Martin,
what are you working on?
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Abby.
I'm building a new website
application for teachers.
And it will use Cloud Run.
Is there an easy
way to get started?
ABBY CAREY: Are you
using Visual Studio Code?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, I am.
ABBY CAREY: Perfect.
Let me show you how you
can use the Cloud Run
extension to build
a starter app,
run it locally, and apply it to
the cloud all within minutes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's take a look
at what we've got here.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I created a
project here in Cloud Console
and created an empty folder
on my local hard drive.
Now, I'm not sure
what to do next.
ABBY CAREY: With Cloud Code,
you can get a hello world app
up and running fast.
Cloud Code has a
repository of samples
that show best practices
for a variety of languages.
They're a good starting
off point and also great
reference for seeing
best practices in action.
Is there a language you're
interested in starting with?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
let's build a Node.js app.
ABBY CAREY: Awesome.
First you'll need to
install Cloud Code.
Go ahead and click
the Extensions icon.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Yep, I did.
ABBY CAREY: Now
type in Cloud Code.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud Code.
Ah, here it is.
ABBY CAREY: Yep.
Hit the Install button.
MARTIN OMANDER:
All right, install.
Installing.
All right.
ABBY CAREY: Now there
are new icons to the left
and a Cloud Code button
in your status bar.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
Yep.
ABBY CAREY: Let's get a hello,
world Node.js sample going.
First click the Cloud Code
button in the status bar.
Then select New Application--
MARTIN OMANDER: New
Application, yep.
ABBY CAREY: --Cloud Run--
MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud
Run Application, yep.
ABBY CAREY: --and
Node.js Cloud Run
MARTIN OMANDER:
Node.js Cloud Run.
OK.
Hello, world 1, sure.
Put it there.
Oh, it's downloading the sample.
Great.
Oh, awesome.
It looks like there's some code
here, index.js and a Docker
file here too.
That's great because
Docker files is sometimes
a little hard to write.
ABBY CAREY: Yep.
These samples can be built
with both Docker or Buildpacks.
MARTIN OMANDER: So, Abby,
you mentioned earlier
that I can run my Cloud
Run service locally.
How would I do that?
ABBY CAREY: Cloud Code comes
with a Cloud Run emulator.
The emulator emulates the
Cloud Run environment locally.
To use it, you'll need to
have Docker installed first.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Let me do a quick search
on how to do that.
Install Docker Mac.
OK, Docker Desktop on Mac.
OK.
So I'll install this.
Let's refill our tea and meet
back up in a few minutes.
ABBY CAREY: Sounds good.
MARTIN OMANDER: I now
have Docker installed.
And I've also started
Docker Desktop
and I can even see a little
Docker symbol up here
in my toolbar.
ABBY CAREY: Awesome.
Let's try running
this locally now.
First let's make sure
you're signed in.
Click the Cloud Code
Cloud Run button.
And now click that little
Login button there.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Click Here to Log In?
ABBY CAREY: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Uh-huh, something's happening.
Oh, look at that.
I want to pick this account.
View my data, view manage
Compute Engine resources.
Sure.
You're now authenticated
with a Google Cloud SDK.
ABBY CAREY: Nice.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yay.
ABBY CAREY: Now back
in VS Code, let's
go ahead and click
the Cloud Code
button at the bottom of the
screen again in the status bar.
MARTIN OMANDER: I seem to
have the wrong project here.
How do I change project?
ABBY CAREY: Oh, yeah,
you have to click
that little Switch button.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, this one.
OK.
Got it.
ABBY CAREY: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's see.
Teacher's Aid, OK.
ABBY CAREY: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Ah, teacher's aid,
no Cloud Run services
in that project.
That sounds about right.
ABBY CAREY: Now go ahead and
click the Cloud Code button
at the bottom of the screen.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud
Code, bottom of the screen.
OK.
I'm here.
ABBY CAREY: Yes.
And now could run on
Cloud Run Emulator.
MARTIN OMANDER: Run
on the emulator.
ABBY CAREY: With
setting it up, you
get the same
configuration options
you'd see when
deploying to the cloud
except you're deploying
locally to the emulator.
Go ahead and in Build Settings,
let's switch the builder
to Buildpacks.
That way, you'll
get hot reloading.
This makes updating
code super fast.
Now, pop open the Show
Advanced Settings.
To best emulate running on
Cloud Run, set CPUs to One
Virtual CPU.
MARTIN OMANDER: CPU, one.
OK.
ABBY CAREY: Now scroll to
the bottom and click Run.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Let's see.
Ah, there it is, Run.
ABBY CAREY: First time
you kick off the elevator
can take around five minutes.
So go grab a snack
to go with that tea.
Future ones will be much faster.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, Abby.
Looks like it's done.
Let's see.
Forwarded URL from
service hello world.
Do I click this link here?
ABBY CAREY: Yep.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Let's have a look.
Oh, look at that.
It's running!
ABBY CAREY: Yeah, that
there is your sample
app running in the emulator.
MARTIN OMANDER: Awesome!
That was super easy.
So now that it's
running in the emulator,
what happens if I make
changes to my code?
ABBY CAREY: Go ahead
and test it out.
Maybe try it updating
the main response
on line 47 of your index.js
file to return a simple message.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
So right now it's compiling
a handlebars template
or something, a template,
and outputting all the HTML
from the template.
But I'll replace that.
So instead it will
say hello world!
And I save that.
Oh, something
happened down here.
It looks like it just updated.
Let me refresh the browser.
Hello world!
It updated.
ABBY CAREY: Cloud Code
supports hot reloading
when building Node.js apps
with Buildpacks, which
makes updates take seconds.
If you instead build
with a Docker file,
a complete rebuild and
redeploy will happen,
which isn't quite as fast.
That update kicked
off after saving
because you have watch
mode turned on in your one
configuration we just made.
It can be turned off at any time
if you don't like this feature.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
That wasn't too difficult.
The Cloud Code's UI
is really similar
to Cloud Console.
But I plan on adding Datastore
to my Cloud Run service.
Can the Cloud Code extension
help me with that too?
ABBY CAREY: It actually can.
Cloud Code has an
integrated GCP API Explorer.
Just click the Cloud Code
API icon to the left there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's see.
It says API here.
Is this the one?
ABBY CAREY: Yep.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see
lots of Google APIs here.
Let's see, databases,
databases--
ooh, Cloud Datastore
API, there it is.
ABBY CAREY: Mm-hmm.
Now, if you scroll
down a little here--
oh, it looks like,
from here, you
can enable the API with
a click and read up
on how you can get it
working in your project.
It looks like Datastore's
enabled by default,
which saves you a click here.
Now go ahead and install
the client library.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
install a client library.
Let's see, not Java.
Node.js-- ooh, this
little Play button there.
Oh, cool.
That runs npm install for
the Datastore library.
Now I've got the Datastore
NPM package installed here.
And so I have--
I can use Datastore.
And then in the
Teachers Aid project,
I had previously set up
Datastore and put some data in.
Let me show you.
So here I put in
the kind, course.
So these are courses.
And I put in two courses so
far, trigonometry and calculus.
ABBY CAREY: Now head
back to VS Code.
There should be a handy
documentation link
to help you get started
with the Datastore API.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's
see, invoke the API--
ah, documentation.
Let's go in and
take a look at that.
So here's some code for the
Cloud Datastore Node.js client,
looks good.
Install the library, OK,
that happened already.
Make this a little bigger.
Using the client library--
OK, this looks promising.
It looks like it's
creating a new entity.
That's not what I want to do.
I want to read my existing
entities, the trigonometry
and calculus courses
from the database.
Let's see, I'll keep
scrolling, error handling,
importing tasks,
delete-- oh, list tasks.
That sounds good.
I'll click there.
All right, good.
Here we have some
code that shows how
to use the Datastore library.
So I guess we need to declare
an import require Datastore
at the top of the code.
So I'll copy that--
let's see-- up here near
the top of the code,
paste those in Datastore.
OK.
Require Datastore.
And it looks like there's a
function called listTasks.
It seems to run a query
against Datastore.
That's looking promising.
I'll just paste that whole
function in here at the top
as well.
And then I guess this
is just a function that
isn't called from anywhere.
So I'll just, at the
beginning of my main
here, I'll just call it.
And it's asynchronous, so
I'll put in await there.
And it looks like the code--
I'm looking at it here.
It prints stuff to the console.
So it doesn't show anything
to the user in the browser.
But it prints to the server log.
It says tasks.
And then it goes over all
the tasks in the database
and prints them out
in the server console.
So I'll just hit Save
again and the output here.
ABBY CAREY: That should trigger
the hot reloading there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Uh-huh.
Very nice.
I see that.
And off to the server we go.
Localhost.
Let me reload this.
Very nice.
It still says Hello world!
I haven't broken anything.
Now, where can I
see my server logs,
these console log statements?
ABBY CAREY: So go ahead
and go back to VS code.
And you see that
little dropdown there
that says Cloud Run, Run Debug?
Click that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
ABBY CAREY: And then switch
to the Detailed view.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, detailed.
Uh-huh.
Very nice.
Ah, here's tasks.
That corresponds to line
27 up here, very good.
And then it should
loop over all the tasks
and print them out
here on line 30.
But it doesn't.
Seems like, Abby, I have
a bug in my code here.
I expect to see the names
of my courses, trigonometry
and calculus.
Is there a way to
debug this error?
ABBY CAREY: Oh, yeah.
First go ahead and click that
Stop button at the top there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Stop.
ABBY CAREY: Now make sure
you have Debug Toggle Auto
Attach set to Smarter Always.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
Debug Toggle Auto Attach,
ah, it's set to Smart already.
Good.
ABBY CAREY: Yeah.
And this makes it so that
we can attach to the running
application for debugging.
Now place a breakpoint
at the problem spot.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I
think here on line 26,
this is where we read
the elements, records,
from the database.
So maybe I'll place a
breakpoint here on 27
so we can expect what the
tasks variable contains.
ABBY CAREY: Looks good.
So now let's go ahead and click
that Cloud Code status bar
again.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Cloud Code-- ah, there it is.
ABBY CAREY: And then click
Debug on Cloud Run Emulator.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
Debug, I see it.
ABBY CAREY: Yep.
Now we're going to
debug this locally.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, it switched
back to Visual Studio Code.
In the debugger here.
I see that because
it's orange status bar.
And, oh, look, it
hit my breakpoint,
this breakpoint on 27.
So let's see here.
Tasks, that's what
I wanted to look at.
So tasks is an array.
That's good.
Oh, an array of length 0.
Hmm, so it's not getting
anything from the database.
Oh, I think I know why.
Here I'm looking for the
task entity in the database.
And my database doesn't
have task entities.
They're course entities.
So I'll copy that.
And I will look for
course entities.
And I won't sort
them by created.
I will sort them by--
because I don't have a created.
They have a name, however,
so I'll sort them by name.
Name, there we go.
I'm saving.
ABBY CAREY: So watch mode
doesn't work while debugging.
So go ahead and to
view your bug fix,
let's detach our debugger by
clicking that little Unplug
button up there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Unplugging.
ABBY CAREY: And hit Stop.
MARTIN OMANDER: Stop.
ABBY CAREY: Now click that
Cloud Code status bar again.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
ABBY CAREY: And then let's Run
Cloud Run Emulator one more
time.
MARTIN OMANDER: One more time.
It looks like it
started running.
I'll hit that local
host URL again.
It says Hello world!
Good, nothing is broken.
And now I'll go back and
check the server logs.
So you said they were
in Details, right?
ABBY CAREY: Yup.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Let's have a look.
Oh, look!
Name, trigonometry,
very nice, and name,
calculus, and sorted by name.
ABBY CAREY: Woo!
Awesome!
Cool, you fixed a bug.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, very nice.
So this little service
is looking great.
Now, if I want to
deploy it to the Cloud,
do I have to figure out
those tricky G Cloud?
ABBY CAREY: No.
Cloud Code can do that for you.
Just like with running
on the emulator,
Cloud Code packages
deploy to the Cloud
in a couple of clicks.
Go ahead and click on
that Cloud Code status bar
again and select
Deploy to Cloud Run.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud Code,
ah, Deploy to Cloud Run.
ABBY CAREY: You can see
all the service options.
Go ahead and keep all the
defaults and just click Deploy.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
there we go, Deploy.
I'm deploying.
ABBY CAREY: And it's now
building your container image,
pushing it to your
Container Registry,
and deploying it Cloud Run.
Managed.
Oh, looks like it's done, go
ahead and click that link.
MARTIN OMANDER: Aha,
hello world at run.app.
Cool.
Let's see.
ABBY CAREY: Now, this is your
service running on Cloud Run.
Anyone can access it now.
MARTIN OMANDER: Woo-hoo!
Feels great to finally get
something running on Cloud Run
and not having to type
any G Cloud commands.
Can you do anything else Cloud
Run related with the Cloud Code
extension?
ABBY CAREY: Yes, now that
you have a Cloud Run service,
you can view its details
from the Cloud Run Explorer.
Let's go ahead and
go back to VS Code
and click that Cloud
Code Cloud Run button.
Yup.
And if you-- there we go.
There's your service.
So if you go ahead and
expand that dropdown there
on your service,
here is where you
can view quick details about
your service, like traffic
allocation and its URL.
What's even cooler is being able
to view the logs of your Cloud
Run service from your IDE.
Go ahead and hover over
your service real quick.
MARTIN OMANDER: Up here?
ABBY CAREY: Yep.
And now click that little
Login button to the right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
This means logging.
Oh, view logs, it
says as a tooltip.
ABBY CAREY: Mm-hmm.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So I get to set up filters,
what logs I want to view.
These look like
reasonable defaults.
I want to see my Cloud
Run logs, and that
has been selected here.
ABBY CAREY: Yep, it also
grabbed it for your service.
So these are all the
logs from your service.
MARTIN OMANDER: Aha!
And look at that, there is
my good friend trigonometry.
And there is calculus.
It works.
Hey, Abby, thanks for showing
me how to run and debug
my Cloud Run service locally
and how to deploy it with one
click.
ABBY CAREY: Yeah, the
Cloud Code extension
makes things pretty simple.
Be sure to install the Cloud
Code extension from the VS Code
Marketplace and give it a try.
Let us know in the comments
what you think about it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]